foreign
[Music]
thank you it's good to be here in Austin
Texas Home of love
my name is Hans Kim and I am a Love Guru
today
what
no don't don't cut no stay back one
second uh so my name is nons I've
personally been on over seven dates
um
I've been racist seeing a Jew
so that's fun
very frugal she's very enamored over any
Financial gift
so try to play very easy
anyways this next guy is not a Jew he is
in fact a beautiful Asian man
what's up y'all
um Prince
foreign
and then she dated this other guy who's
like a scammer oh yeah so I didn't want
to get in trouble with that and I walk
out of my job recently like the day
before Valentine
you're like I'm not gonna even try with
this [__]
yeah other job or the job yeah that's
more important yeah so I'm currently in
need of a job so if anybody know of a
good job let me know
and if you're interested
you could have an office romance bring
your own boyfriend to work
hire him and [__] him
[Laughter]
okay
uh well we have a lot of gays in the
bucket or is that just empty empty
sheets
I think those are just empty sheets
the gays don't support us like that
but if you wanted to we would love to
sign you up we only have one sign up
today and that was me that is
our guest house I know you just sign
your name up and then you just open to
whatever abuse we hurl at you
um oh there's a little piece of gum in
here so uh
look at this yeah
you're gonna be on stage buddy uh yeah
yeah yeah we match up two people one of
two people so uh we're gonna need people
to sign up from the opposite sex
yeah for this to work
whatever you identify as ma'am
oh nice thank you ma'am we got is
appreciate it all coming up
wait she's signing up people are signing
up get out of the way you goddamn lady
foreign
are using the gay bucket as a storage
class
so we should explain the bucket we have
a lgbtq bucket a straight mail bucket
and a straight woman bucket so sure
you're gay we really need a straight
yeah we've been in here straight so I
hope your Ace please help out the show
the show will go much better you guys
sign up yes yeah a lot of people in
relationships today uh do you know
what's gonna happen after you sign up
you get pick out a bucket you get mad to
a person and then you go on stage and
you guys talk for like three minutes 90
seconds and then we interview you guys
so it's really risk-free yes risk-free
and you might meet somebody cool
yeah or Ishmael
he's pretty cool
he's also from Pflugerville Ismail come
on up here all right all the way from
the flukes don't you have to pick
another one we're gonna get to know
Ismail and then that'll get the ladies
okay
and then we'll see who's gonna come up
and snatch up this prize
who's gonna put this wiener schnitzel in
their mouth
it's Ishmael yeah get back for Ishmael
oh yeah even in the game uh dating game
show I get stood up damn
we got our first contestant thank you
for signing up very tiny piece of paper
that you put your name on I I thought
that the like other one was super full
so that's why I rolled it I don't know
uh he has a sense of balance yeah he's
trying to I don't know what he's doing
Ismail so what is your sex life been so
far
uh it's been kind of weird weird yeah is
in terms of like kinkiness
uh just doing stuff that I've never done
before I guess oh but dudes
no I've been doing dudes for a while now
I'm just kidding he's got a sense of
humor ladies
yeah what is the funniest thing that
you've done on a date
oh um funniest thing I've done on a date
like just dating or like sexual wise or
like it don't really matter
of the above yeah let's let's hear it
well I I mean let me preface I dated
this girl for like six years but the
first time I had sex with her I came on
my face oh yeah you came on your face
yeah self facials I didn't know that [__]
shots were like I I thought that's what
that was you know oh okay no it was it
was just accidental you must have came
really hard it was like
well she was sitting on me and you know
yeah I just
pulled out oh she was like oh gross and
then she like just dismounted and then
you're like whoa yeah but I I guess
that's how it happens after you did that
then you went that was meant for you no
dude I was like I meant to do that
I'm gonna stick with you for six years
so no one has to find out about this
pretty much so why are you here Ishmael
do you need a green card
he yes all right who's gonna sponsor
this charismatic Mexican boy
let's see who the lucky lady is yep how
old are you Ishmael 29 29.9 it's Cindy
Cindy
just for fun come on
wow you need to play your card right
Ishmael
going on a date for 90 seconds
let's see what they have to say to each
other
starting now
hello Cindy where are you from I am from
originally I'm from Austin but
originally from
Fort Lauderdale oh right on what brought
you to Austin
um
originally I was from Texas born in
Texas and I moved back oh right on cool
cool
um I've been here since 2017. I've been
here for a few years uh came to watch a
bunch of comedy shows and I love movies
what do you like to do for like on your
free time
[Music]
uh beer or wine
let's put that mic right by your chin
we had a giant beer last night but uh
why okay right on how about you I I like
beers okay I like I prefer razor uh
pretty much anything but tonight it's a
Saturday night okay also because I think
they're the cheapest today okay
but uh what do you do for work a Frugal
guy great
on an unemployed comedian y'all what's
up but uh what do you do for work or
uh
I'd dig them I'm into you take them yeah
for sure what does that mean to you uh I
mean I feel like universally I could
treat anyone correctly you know the
right way the way they're supposed to be
treated
and in your mind what is the right way
uh just respectfully you know
I feel like that was a tricks question
what are we talking about a time
okay for Ishmael and Cindy thank you
Cindy how did that date make you feel
be honest it's fine they make you feel
young again
[Laughter]
Ismail a very old soul yeah he's got
wisdom Beyond his ears very nice guy
yeah Ishmael when you say that you treat
Cindy respectfully does that mean that
when y'all have sex you're gonna come on
yourself
gentlemen like thing to do here what a
gentleman he's gonna soil himself what
do you think that's very sexy I can't
wait oh wow
wow you found somebody with that fetish
[Laughter]
um I know it's the first question you
asked Cindy was where are you from so
you were making sure that she could
sponsor you right she didn't say any
place weird like New Zealand uh no I
just wanted I was generally curious most
people that you meet in Austin are
always like I'm not from here you know
so that's why I ask where are you from
are you from here Israel are you a proud
not at all I'm from like Deep South
Texas like six hours away from here not
San Antonio Mexico yeah like 30 minutes
away from the border and that's not a
blow his cover
yeah you already did that
um that's cool you're from to South
Texas you're here in Austin you're
trying to you're talking to White Chicks
yep what's your favorite thing about
white women
um
I mean like residency you asked her they
have a green card no um no I mean a side
table income aside from stable income
and good credit
um green wallet green card I don't know
I just I think growing up in South Texas
we don't have any white people so just
the fact that so they're exotic yeah to
us in a way yeah
an exotic American yeah they don't
survive well in South Texas with the UV
rays yeah
so uh you asked her if she was into beer
or wine is that your subtle way of
finding out how white is this [__]
Kinda Yeah and you said you drank a
giant beer yesterday what was what
happened yesterday that made you drink a
giant beer I did but it was
white it was Miller Lite a Miller Lite
oh wow I'm sorry one of the whitest
drinks sorry bigger lovers
a beautiful Miller Light
and you're from Fort Lauderdale which is
close to Miami correct how did you enjoy
your time in Florida compared to Texas
[Music]
and uh high school college so I enjoyed
it quite a bit wow nothing better than
that means cocaine
where was Burnett before she went to
Fort Lauderdale and
this is all the residual cocaine in her
hair it was flowing it was flowing wow
what did you like about what was the
craziest thing that happened while you
were in Fort Lauderdale oh my God
[Music]
well you have to account for my age so
okay so this was
lots lots of
lots of parties
[Music]
and we would just skip from one hotel
room to the next oh that was that was
the norm oh [__] oh wow we're getting
into hotel rooms not even in the
ballrooms no so you're saying you were
working in housekeeping
she goes from hotel to hotel bring in
fresh sheets she might know my mom
[Laughter]
what goes on inside hotel rooms I would
think that's the end result are there
like part the people partying inside
hotel rooms yeah
and being a high school girl you
couldn't wait for spring break wow
that's not their childhood I never had
we're all just fascinated you got three
years yeah
we also have a crazy spring break in
South Texas what do you do there you
pick more fruit so uh
that's on our downtown
so we have uh so we have we actually
have two we have uh like the spring
break and then we have if you know
Spanish Semana Santa uh it's a whole
week of people from Mexico Canada and a
bunch of parts of like the world that go
and party for that Canada celebrates
they just go because it's a big party
okay but it's like an extended spring
break is this a thing in Canada they're
like let's go the Mexicans are in heat
right now
it's a win-win dude it's a win-win yes
so what is that all about what is the
theme of Semana De Santa
I should know but I just I mean I know
it's not supposed to be like a party
thing but it's used it's actually like a
religious thing but uh they use it as
just another excuse to get drunk
some of that communion wine yeah yeah I
think it's gonna work out between you
two because uh Ishmael he could pick the
the grape that you use for your wine
Cindy
it's like non-GMO you know
I'm finally going to check out a Costco
then this time never been to one oh wow
yeah oh yeah I've never been to Costco
we know uh you have an executive
membership at Costco
no uh
okay disappoint yeah not as white as I
thought
what is the whitest thing that you've
done today
wake up
never mind yeah
okay I I put Tanner on last night so
Tanner self tanner oh yeah that's pretty
wild nice how what's I don't know what
South 10 is like
self tanner it's like a strip you put on
to make you darker
yeah
okay well we got an expert Tanner right
here how did you get your tan
as you can tell I don't even wear it can
screen like yeah you could tell
but I know as if um
long tracks across the border right yeah
yeah
we'll see fun fact about crossing the
border um this is actually a true story
I I got crossed over the Border back
then they wouldn't check your your
papers when you're a baby uh this was
like before 9 11 and uh yeah so I didn't
I'm not technically like someone that
crossed the river you know I I
technically crossed like the most legal
but legal way possible so you have fake
paperwork so you're saying when I was a
kid yeah
where do you get a paperwork from I
don't know I was too dude
where my parents got it from but
borrowed it from some other white kid I
don't know how does that make you feel
Cindy
oh this guy didn't follow the rules
bad boy he's a bad boy oh unintentional
bad boy he's a bad baby
what did you like bad boys I do what is
uh was something it's never worked well
for me yeah Bad Boys usually you know
they go to jail or they cheat on you or
something correct what is uh what is it
like the second choice I don't not the
first okay yeah yeah what is it that you
like about bad boys
um
Chase
and the Mystery
well unfortunately I don't think it
smells gonna be really good for a Chase
[Laughter]
you don't want to get caught I already
been in the country for a while you know
I'm used to the chase yeah hold on
as well what's something that you could
do to initiate a Chase
what did I could do to initiate a Chase
yeah like for me yeah oh I don't know
why I was like why would like
um I thought like why would I initiate
the border patrol to like chase me but
uh um I don't know
um just take out some cocaine
pull out pull out some wine box wine
yeah oh
yeah
I was saying more like you know treat
them rough you get the Muff
oh
what a nice toy yay so nice
he's right there for you Cindy right for
the picking
yes I mean I think Ishmael you want you
know Cindy to chase you
then just don't come on yourself you
know come on your target never again
yeah that way they'll chase you to wipe
it off of them
uh what's something that you like about
dating women
I'm not really picky like if they like
if they like food and they're funny
do you like food Cindy because you might
be his type
oh wow
I like to eat you got a lot in common we
do yeah automatically you guys both
breathe oxygen yeah yeah
what do you like to do uh on a date with
men Cindy
um
just your Norm just your Norm cocktail
cocktail see if we're buying
maybe dinner
over a nice inside of a country club and
no go golfing no no you're going with
the stereotype I'm not following okay
you're an independent white woman
correct you don't follow the Norms
someone I got home cooked meal that's
you that were you man I love to cook
yeah I'm a very good cook so you would
like to cook for your date or you had to
have them cook for you
I like I'd like to do it together I
think that's fun oh nice so what are
some things you guys gonna cook together
some Tex-Mex which as you can tell I'm
not picky with food
um
he's self-deprecating yeah I I don't
know I'm pretty basic I like like
chicken alfredo okay
okay angel hair pasta I mean if a white
person mixed with a Mexican person
they'll turn it down in
Italians are not white oh really
that's a history lesson for you yeah
okay so you guys think that you like
want to like you know maybe make out
right now or
um
sad thing right there
yeah I won't do that to you I promise no
it's what a modest what a very uh you
know polite person you are Ismail is
down Ismail was already licking his lips
I mean you know that was back in the
hotel Days
just imagine this is one hotel room you
could be right about that yeah Hotel
parties that's amazing what did you uh
what is the craziest thing that you saw
in one of these Hotel parties
[Music]
um there was a vast variety of how
people were addressed or possibly
undressed and lots of flowing uh
narcotics and black lights and
throbbing music
[Music]
I'm uh I'm excited
[Laughter]
Israel are you uh worried about black
lights and throbbing music it sounds
like a Detention Center at the border
that sounds kind of fun actually
sound like it'll be really easy to see
the calm you know with the Black Knights
yeah all over ishmael's face
oh man shouldn't we pull new names yeah
let's pull new names all right y'all
thank you so much I appreciate it give
up for them here tonight
[Applause]
let's get to know the lady first this
time we got a lady named Kathy
Kenny we got Cindy now we got Kathy
coming up
Kathy
coming from Cindy's table
thank you Cindy and Kathy
hello Kathy hello Kathy were you also in
Fort Lauderdale
you just met here with Cindy yes what is
it like you guys like to do besides
drink Miller lights
oh you're classy
yeah I vodka straight up hug and
straight up holy [__] you really want to
party tonight
what's uh what's the craziest thing that
you've seen at a party
can't sake
she's Bound by an NDA she works for Elon
Musk
I don't know
okay so what are you looking for tonight
in a man
um somebody that's fun
fun
Ismail
humorous
look at that mustache it's humorous
so uh are you excited to meet this new
man sure sure okay uh it's Aaron hook
Aaron hop
kins it's Aaron hug
the hugmeister himself
no music for Aaron
come up in silence
okay that music matches his vibe
90 seconds of Aaron and Kathy all right
this is gonna be great
we're going to be a match made in heaven
I believe
hi what's your name again Kathy Kathy my
name is Aaron hug the hug Meister has
Hans uh knows already somehow he must
know me from childhood
but uh how are you doing today good
about you I'm doing all right I'm doing
all right I've actually got off tomorrow
from work took a holiday so I've got a
four day weekend actually because I took
off Friday also I'm trying to take off
the rest of the week and every other
week in the future but I don't know how
I'll do that
I work from home actually okay yeah
um I am trying to not work ever again
somehow how's that working for you it's
not working because I haven't gotten
naked on film yet oh okay the day will
come
only only fans I haven't tried I'm too
ashamed of
of putting myself out there but the day
that's I don't know
do you have a suggestion
no
one suggestion feet my feet yeah I had a
girl a date I
a date
that I had sex with about it two months
ago like my feet she said they're not so
bad seeing big when you're big your feet
get uglier do you know that fact no not
many people do because you know for
everybody
we'll tell people no the top Community
knows hi
um over six one six two for men over 5
10 5 11 for women I believe isn't that
how it goes usually
yeah the toes get longer they start
looking like hands
and time get up first Cindy Kathy and
Aaron hug
give it up for Aaron hug and Kathy
did you just call me Cindy yes okay
I'm sorry
it's okay you're excused so uh was that
your fetish Kathy foot feet is that your
fetish
no no
I noticed you look at your table and
your friend she went her feet like
oh yeah that's how you make money
on only fans yeah if you do your feet
okay so does that apply to male or
female or like you have to be a female I
think it's a female is it everybody
everyone has feet
you can jerk off to anyone with a foot
most people have feet except for those
quadriplegics yeah
yeah they still have a feet don't they
oh yeah I'm sure they like it they'll
pay for feet Yes because they don't have
any of their own yeah they don't have
any other options they're living
vicariously
so uh Aaron hug
how are your feet
well they're they're pretty good
how are your archers they're actually
that's the best part of them the Arches
oh he's got curves ladies and the big
toes I believe are pretty nice
Aaron what would you do with your foot
with
Kathy would I do
what would I do you have a foot I have
two you have to what what would you do
sexually with your feet it depends which
foot the right or the left I had no one
thing you could do you could pick up the
vodka with your foot and then put it to
Kathy mouth
as I explained my toes are like fingers
climb trees yeah that's how you get into
Kathy heart the supporting Block in her
mouth with my feet yeah
it could be she says she's not using her
mic she doesn't want me I mean you drink
enough vodka you'll be into anything
I don't know about that because Aaron
really hates working at all so maybe we
need to find something you can do on his
back with his feet
Aaron why do you hate working
what you uh you don't have a work ethic
you're just like you don't you just want
to quit jobs all the time or what what
do you do like why I'm a hard worker
I've worked my whole life and I've had a
lot of crappy jobs and horrible managers
and this job actually pays pretty well
but it's a it's a sales job
um I work from home on the computer and
talk to people and it's mad sounds like
an owner
all right he's a male prostitute but but
lately the sales because of the whole
Tech thing and everything's busting it's
not it's not easy everything's busting
on your feet
I bust while I work I bust while I don't
work oh he matches from my version of
Arnold Schwarzenegger's uh
what was his you know guys famous line
cares no okay uh
Kathy what do you think about this young
entrepreneurial man he's out there he's
working he's got feet
it's great he's great right What A Catch
he looks sort of like uh you know like a
little downsy but in a good way I got
hit in the head when I was like five
years old really hard and almost died on
the playground
oh my God who hit you a big Iron Horse
one of those things that oh no
yeah no the big springs on the ground oh
okay and they're like iron cast they
don't have them very often you have to
go to like some ghetto spots now that
never took them out
yeah I think they had them on swinging
too I think they were swings
away no I've tried to run straight
across it because I used to watch that
movie uh never-ending Story and there's
the the scene where was it Atreyu had to
run through the horses before they shot
him with the laser I was like I could do
this
I didn't got me
woke up in my arms just screaming bloody
murder how old were you when you did
this 35
no no that's another story when I was 20
25 and almost died but uh got hit or
knocked unconscious but
um yeah so that's probably half of my uh
what a bad my brain functioning he runs
through playgrounds
Cindy is really attracted to bad boys
like that are you do you like bad boys
she's
your friend
who is your friend with an attitude I
I think she wants to come up you'll find
them like a cocaine dealer come up and
date me real quick
I like bad boys too oh
I've been known to be I can't say I am
but I have been known to be on the sales
force he's known as the laziest worker
what was it was that what do you do when
you
when you're what do I do
well I just like to say that this is
probably why I don't have a relationship
because this date
if I could see the video of this
I'm not I'm not making the moves I'm not
smooth talking and now I'm about to
start talking about ass eating
wow that's not a good first date you ask
me I'm so honest I'm so very honest
what's the what's what is it that you
like about ass eating dude I don't well
I mean
I'm not the one eating it that's what I
like about
oh he's a bottom Bravo wow
wow Cindy Cindy oh Kathy Kathy Kathy
that's
right there
Kathy what do you like
uh about buttholes
not much
do you have you ever eaten a man's
butthole no
look at this guy he's like got the
perfect face for getting his butt in
wipes
it's good to know
I think thoroughly thoroughly clean I
mean you gotta yeah play the part to
play the role
do you have a bad idea clean up before
an ass eating sesh no no I spend extra
time in the shower just scrubbing
scrubbing and scrubbing there's a couple
of different soaps you're thinking about
the user experience
I think about that experience to be the
nice guy that I am truly
okay so when you're getting your ass
eaten what is it that you're thinking
about
the next time I'm gonna get my ass eaten
so you're saying it's a lot like cocaine
pretty much it's very addictive very
addictive when did you first discover
Your Love of getting your butthole
licked
it was 2002.
I was dating a woman a girl named Cindy
actually wow she was a Jamaican this is
a true story uh in Philadelphia where
around Cindy from uh Jamaica from
Jamaica she moved over with her father
um because her parents split that's the
whitest name for a Jamaican was she
white no she was a beautiful beautiful
she's the only black woman black Cindy
in the world beautiful black woman and
she was going down on your Cindy very
hot well she said she said look she
wanted to suck my nipples
and she wanted to eat my butt and she
came right out with it we dated it for a
couple years so about a year in we got
this is a white man's fantasy
so she said woman she's wanted to treat
you like a woman
I I felt awkward about the whole thing I
was young I was 22 very still somewhat
inexperienced my butthole was tight and
fresh
it was
she has Jamaicans eating like a jerk
chicken
laughs
I mean she probably did think of that I
guess wow I like jerk chicken and
Jamaican food's delicious I bet it makes
your butthole tingle right
question yes make him a bad boy how does
getting your butthole eating make your
butt I think that makes you a gay boy
I mean gay people are all bad by
Kaepernick standards yeah they're
breaking rules yeah he's a bati man as
they say in Jamaica
so we then asked what do you do for a
living Kathy
what do you do for a job
I'm a nurse manager wow a hero hero
she's manages Heroes sound like a
stressful job
yeah pretty much
would you like to nurse this guy's
butthole
necess
that
well the truth
don't you have to like put a thing in
their butthole when they're like in a
coma I have you have I've put a lot of
things in a lot of different but uh
holes what kind of butthole do you think
Aaron hugg would have a tight one or one
that's easy for an intubate
you want to help me out here
well naturally it's a perfect butthole
okay perfect but but the only the only
thing it does need to be manscaped
buy them today anyway
um that was Cindy Cindy said if I shave
my nipples and I shave my butt she would
eat my butt and suck my nipples I said
deal I ran into the bathroom and all
this history that was the first my first
oh wow now the world knows
no well I don't have a manscape actually
like the actual version the the product
but I have a thing
that doesn't cut you when you shave
because you don't want that being cut
you got a butthole shaver I'll cut
almost any part of my body with you know
when I'm shaving you are white you love
to cut yourself
well I've been through some hard times
Hans
I've been through some hard times your
butthole's been through some hard times
I've slept more in my vehicle than you
have in my life wow he's a vehicle
dweller not lately not he's not a
different periods of my life he's uh
been through hard times now he's on top
he's uh he's a white man living in a
white man's world Kathy what do you
think about this this strange
strange White
cute
oh nice
does he remind you of doctors at the
hospital
uh no not really
if he were to come to your line of work
as a patient what do you think would be
wrong with him just right off the bat
what disease
erectile dysfunction
s
putting things in one and only fans oh
you have those people that come to you
with stuff like went all the way up the
butthole
right well I don't work in the Ed I
actually work I'm a PD nurse so I don't
necessarily
I suppose not adult bottles oh even
worse
the tiniest of buttholes all right
they're actually cute
little buttholes
okay we got your lawyer here
that's her job
her job is kids buttholes
we all were kids once we all have
buttholes that's exactly right
so what is like the uh the the strangest
thing that you've had to do recently at
your job
don't say it
well recently no because I'm a manager
um so I don't quite see as many you know
many crazy things as I have before but I
have seen like adult uh
lie about their age and they actually
came in to the PD Hospital instead oh
wow they identify as a younger person
yes they identify as a younger person
and you try to come on to the nurses
and I did that once when I was well
hear me out it was it was a party I was
uh 26.
I got sheep shot cold [__] I put on a
record I was we all were drunk we're at
a house party and some guy just comes up
and punches me as hard as he can
and I like fell took a knee and I was
Dazed out of it and I got up and I was
like what's going on to my friend and
he's like so he's just got he he just
hit you so I went to the bathroom blood
my lip had a hole when I opened my mouth
had a hole in it because my tooth went
through the lip
and so my friends were like we got to
get you to get stitches and the closest
hospital was the children's hospital so
that's where we went I didn't have
insurance at the time but they were
really cool I had an insurance card from
my old job I figured I'd keep it on my
purse and just in case I could try to
trick them if I needed it and it kind of
worked they said well this isn't taken
I'm like look at this child with an
insurance card from his old work
so
we went in the doctor was really nice
but while he was stitching me up the
nurses were going by the door
and I was like doctor that's what we
want isn't it and he was he was all he
was laughing we're having a good old
time as he was stitching me up but
anyway story didn't
pan out as well as I thought it did
started out good
okay
interesting story tell a story is like
an old white dude what uh what what
where do you usually go on dates with
like men like this guy
dinner and drinks dinner and drinks the
old school wine and dine drinks and
dinner first drinks first dinner next
why drink first
liquid courage oh I hear you she's
listening to his stories
so what did you think about that story
do you think that maybe you shouldn't
fraud defraud uh Healthcare companies
probably not yeah defraud them
sounds like uh you probably have his
name sounds like a bad boy right they
came after me and that's exactly right
they came after me and I paid them a
thousand over a thousand dollars and
then they came after me for another
thousand I told them off and they said
okay we'll get that expunged off the
you've already paid like 1200 for three
stitches so let's say this guy comes
into your office and he's trying not to
pay
what uh what would you say to him like
what do you think that that conversation
would be like
so you want to do it out of the goodness
of your heart no
I think that's the kind of attitude
Aaron hugg would like some a strong
woman to tell him no
Aaron are you how's your butthole
feeling right now
it's a little little tight little a
little scared I don't know what to say
about uh any of this but um
would you marry me
oh wow okay oh this is a big moment sure
oh wow wow oh
give it up for all that hugs Kathy all
right skip on a date it's straight to
anal now
well thank you guys for being on stage
you guys really hit it off and I can't
wait to see where you guys end up Scott
got mad at the Iraq
congrats
let's get a straight mail up here
going on a date
is
Ty that's your name Jack hey I still
quantify Jack Horner
Jackie H coming on up
going on a date with the only woman and
then we got an LGBT plus woman
I mean person
all right double waiting
no we're just gonna get to Know Jack
Horner a little bit
there he comes Jackie H yeah give up
with Jackie he's been on kill Tony
before
[Applause]
um
to bring kill Tony not you listen I'm
famous ladies I'm famous big penis two
things I want to get off right off the
bat right Ty wow coming off strong yeah
what is it that you like to tell women
uh when you meet them on a date ah big
penis like big penis because like here's
the thing I don't know if you guys like
were paying attention to me when I
walked up here very crippled very sad
very very very very sad very crippled I
want to talk to you guys about this
because I'm a crippled man trying to
date right so I got to bring up my big
penis you know and I'm not saying it's
like big big I'm just saying it's
disproportionately big okay he's got a
big penis I think I'm saying six six
point six inches is that why you have
trouble walking yes yes his penis is
crippling him that's what he's saying
exactly no that's exactly what I'm
saying it's a medical fact like if you
look at my birth like Mom pregnant you
know like whatever what are those called
your mom had a big dick yeah yeah yeah
uh she was the first trans woman to have
a baby yeah and then I was I was born
premature which is sad but it's still a
scientific miracle
okay okay all right a lot of uh uh big
dick energy trans mom yeah
yeah you think he walks weird now you
should see him with a boner uh no I I
have a full-on boner right now which is
part of the problem you can't see it you
know he's talking through his boat
full-on boner uh you know 4.1 inches
that's the name you guys know what I'm
talking special well I can't wait for
the Navy that's about to come up here
it'll be like hey I hope you have a big
vagina to accommodate Keiko caico here
she comes all right from the table where
all the women are coming from tonight
oscillating oh yeah thank you so much we
appreciate what's up get a microphone
what's up a loud mouth I like your body
art cake you can hear me without the
microphone
microphone okay yeah they could hear me
without the microphone too
that's fine it's it's increased a little
bit recently
oh really a third date because it's
usually the second date I bring it up so
just wait one more game
um we're meeting these ladies uh well
debate the basic sites like Okay Cupid
okay Cupid's a good one
like in real life well
isn't that everybody these days wait
hold on a second
oh
keep on going okay so I know I want to
ask everybody on stage the last five
gates you've been on they're not virtual
what the [__] like no it's not right I
haven't been on dates in like four years
oh so you're in a relationship I was oh
okay
Oh okay that's cool that's cool can I be
a part of a throuple maybe I'm not down
into thrupples or three maybe a
threesome but not like a throttle I
don't okay in a night that's that's okay
with me while we're hitting it off guys
this is love oh my God we're not talking
off we just agree yeah well that's
hitting it off right like you agree on
something no yeah
right now I'm not okay
Fair okay so let's let's rewind forget I
talked about my erection right now okay
let's move on listen we're gonna rewind
okay okay so we just met okay I haven't
said anything that I've already said hey
how's it going that's a very interesting
tattoo like is that a geisha yeah oh wow
it's a gay time oh [__] oh yeah
oh yeah what yeah yeah thank you for
coming on this date Keiko and Horner
Corner yeah my name is John Horner yeah
Johnny eight John Jack whatever the [__]
it makes sense well you have a boner
yeah put your last name yeah so this
looks like uh make a wish well kind of
why would I say it no we were trying to
know please you intervene too soon to
say that hold on a second you you
intervened too soon
yeah because we were about to start a
conversation I asked you about her
tattoo of a Geisha and she was you don't
want to go down that path don't ask
about tattoos okay oh so don't ask about
tattoos
exactly I agree yes
so you shouldn't ask about tattoos I
like your glasses thank you yeah no
honestly like this is when I first got
vision insurance and I could afford good
glasses
[__] yeah
insurance I got all my health checked
out teeth ethernet wow that's cool when
did you decide to get pink hair how long
have you had pink hair
excited about five years ago but it had
it a year okay are you worried about
like like why do you have pink hair like
what is it like we're worried about
anything while I have it is because like
I just get bored with my life and like
just life in general
in general okay so Hans just raised his
hand what the [__] was that like what do
you want to say something Hans John
please stop trying to control the show
we're having a great time you know John
what do you what do you think about
women with pink hair do you have like
any preconceived notions yeah yeah I
kind of do right because
because of the preconceived notions they
have about me she's been all
preconceived notions since she came up
on stage what is your preconceived
notion about [__] men I don't have
any yeah
well actually I have a lot of Notions
about you since you started speaking not
being conceived what are some of those
Notions about yourself
well I I think that's fair 100 okay but
I think it's Universal in terms of like
human emotions and experience everybody
views life from their own perspective
but what I want to say about
preconceived notions I've talked for
like 30 seconds and just because I
talked about my boner for like a minute
and a half doesn't mean I'm a bad guy
that's what I'm saying nobody said that
it's a good guy with a boner yeah
oh yeah that's fair that's fair okay you
guys are really talking a lot yeah this
yeah no isn't it yeah
it is yeah I'm toxic so can I be honest
though like you don't want people asking
about that tattoo like because you're
not you can ask I just don't like when
people ask like what is the meaning or
like when they do an open-ended tattoo
because most people's tattoos are really
deep and meaningful and it's a really
like kind of awkward conversation okay
and it's on their body they're talking
about their body
[Applause]
what's your relationship with Kathy and
Cindy that's an interesting table over
there oh oh hi wow my ladies of the
night
oh those are your Geisha you hired
escorts is that what ladies ladies yeah
no they're not escorts
it usually means prostitutes
you guys are all nurses
we all work together okay what are you
the janitor
are you a patient you use that pink hair
as a mop lady or what
oh God yes I wish it was a janitor no
I'm a clinical assistant
oh a clinical assistant what is the most
clinical thing you've seen today besides
John Horner
my favorite the other day a catheter
coming out of somebody's vagina you saw
one that's like a natural birth you
don't see those in the wild
ER seeing that you should look
oh that is why I will never have kids
are you into natural births no I don't
like you're on all the birthdays so just
from like uh like okay natural birth
you got IUD you got it
control IEDs
uh John what do you think about this
wild lady oh so no natural birth is that
when you have like the inflatable pool
and then you fill it up and then you
like do the dance like natural birth
oh
her natural is living in Austin and
dating Texas he's talking to guys like
me that's a natural
I'm just not dating or not sleeping oh
okay right on right on yeah like like I
I thought you meant like natural birth
like no like [__] back shot that like
kills all the pain I was confused that's
my bad so you but you're there for birth
you saw a female catheter I had a
catheter put in my dick once is that is
that good that's where they go catheter
oh
but I have a vagina like a [__] oh
but no I had a catheter in my dick once
okay wow what what happened was it for
business or pleasure uh no uh neither I
was in a car accident and that was like
my first memory like waking up and then
like getting the catheter pulled out of
my dick like oh my God that must have
been a long time pleasure even very much
so yeah it was the most pleasurable
moment of my life the pain the pleasure
you understand what I'm talking about
right Ty are you into DM or what is that
not DMT that not [__] dominatrix [__]
no what is that uh well what's the
letter of [__] uh SMD what are like
yeah SM yeah are you into SM [__] BDS
BDSM yeah no I thought you were talking
about a drug oh I'm thinking of a new
LSD
um I never try it so I don't know you
know well luckily we don't need chains
to tie you up just yeah
yeah no
yarn would work oh wait what I didn't
get what just put some stairs around him
he can't move that's very true I can't
move right now I've stayed in the same
position for like the last five minutes
and I'm gonna need a nurse up here maybe
a clinical assistant yeah
can't really help help you or save you
from stuff I can pull a IV out and call
a nurse well I'm only mildly handicapped
so yell for a clinical assistant and I
will laugh at you and I could do that oh
I guess I'm a clinical assistant too
yeah
um what is the craziest nurse that you
work with besides Kathy
[Laughter]
another lady that worked in the pdicu
oh [__] she's like taking care of dying
children yeah
yeah my mom was in the oh sorry it was
my mom she's in the pdicate I tried I
try to I guess
did someone say I see you I was in the
ICU as a kid yeah when I was born I was
in the ICU for like three months I was
like when I was born like so for the
first I'm 31. oh you might have
uh
was it you no it was a doctor's fault
wow it was a doctor's fault
Dallas I was born in Dallas I was born
kind of close to here how does your body
feel
yeah
I mean um
has anyone in the ICU been like you know
I might be in the ICU but I see you girl
I was like I dealt with kids so
and I hope they didn't
yeah because kids that would be scary
because usually I would call the police
right so what would you guys do on the
first date
um so uh let's see this like it would be
a table with a red tablecloth that's
very like Valentine's you know very like
alive and then I would make small talk
like this without you guys being here
and it still wouldn't it still wouldn't
go very well obviously but hopefully it
would be what do you have in common with
uh
uh Keiko I dig the body art you know I
want to uh I want to know more about her
you seem very interesting like I brought
the pink hair like because it's like
yeah no I'm a little weird I'm a little
off it's like
care like tells you the wrong story
because I I'm not I'm actually very
formal and conservative and all of that
amazing conservative with pink hair cool
you're very concerned what does that
mean to you like politically you're
conservative
or just like just
cool
okay right on yeah I said open again
like but like so like what would be
would be a good first day for you is it
this [__] like for me would we would
start off I would pick you up oh you
would not have to even think about
anything you would just you'd be able to
arrive there
I would arrive ready to pick you up
where are we going hush you have no idea
I would take you to your favorite thing
would it be art oh it's art so we're
going to Art in the Park sure there's a
lot of ramps and then yeah there is
Waterloo Greenway so there's a lot of
rain Waterloo Greenway if you haven't
been it's new it's on 12th Street
there's a lot of ramps it's handicap
friendly shush let me finish my night
okay let me finish my night
damn it I already forgot okay so we're
at the art show and because that's
something that you love and it is
handicap friendly whatever you need it
to be friendly if you want to walk if
you want to crawl if you want to roll
whatever the hell and then we go to your
favorite restaurant where I buy you the
best drink and you love dessert so I get
you some dessert and then we go off and
bang all night wow that sounds awesome
okay so you said the freezer you said
the first date that's a great date
fantastic date I want to say like you
said the freeze pick me up though like
pick me up Sir you I know you meant your
car but like literally like you mean
literally pick me up like if you
literally pick me up
exactly
because he brought up ramps yeah
that's and that's okay with me I'm just
saying he brought up ramps and stairs
stairs are a problem for me so if you're
willing to pick me up in the hard spots
oh okay okay
ramp it up but I'm but you're willing to
pick me up and that's what matters in
the relationship
spiritually once maybe twice at the end
of the night like not throughout
but it's yeah the beginning and the end
is the most important part right yes so
Jack yeah hi so John yeah I don't give a
[__] I know I'm more uh you know
I'm good thank you for asking you know
how much did you smoke
you can't ask an Asian how much they
smoke my eyes are always like this yeah
um so John I think you would have a
great chance of getting made if you
don't say a word yeah and she'll just
handle everything from beginning to end
it's impossible yeah it's impossible
going to fall buddy
but yeah did you write that no but
that's just my personality I over talk
like I can't not say a word it's
impossible dude it's just that your dick
do the talking
yeah be cool and did a strong silence or
the silent type oh yeah no
no
it if I'm silent and just like mildly
handicapped it's like I don't feel like
that's a good thing I feel like it's
good to be strong and mildly handicapped
and like not silent you know because I'm
not silent that's a big personality I'm
compensating right John the older I get
I feel like I I let people take care of
me pick me up carry me wherever you want
to go no I'm not fighting you anymore
yeah you think I'm you think I can't
walk you think I'm too drunk okay
[Music]
what's your relationship with your dad
like
ah it's great we don't speak but I mean
we're friends I'm glad that you don't
speak it seems like you'd get into some
Fierce arguments
I mean he's white
arguments would I get into
uh politics yeah is your data
conservative conservative no
okay it's just a regular white guy that
doesn't have a lot of opinions so uh did
you uh have pink hair before you stopped
talking to her dad or after
just here in the last year I stopped
talking to my dad like 20 years ago so
this has been something to be making wow
20 years of no contact with you oh yeah
we're going reconcile
on a regular basis but I like have
contact with them okay you know who he
is I know who he is I know where he
lives and all that well that's that's
pretty uh that's a lot for someone with
pink hair
yeah my issues are not my daddy issues
okay I have like issues
what is one of your biggest issues
that I'm talking to you about my
oh that's
men I think that women that have pink
hair have something that's going on in
their life as opposed to just wanting to
be [__] cute
well yes and I trust people for having
pink hair and it's really gross and
toxic I bought up the pink hair I bought
up the pink hair that's the guy that
brought it up but I bought it for pink
hair and here's why because I knew
someone that just had wigs you know
because like they explained to me that
the dye is bad you know what I'm saying
so I was just wondering like do you just
dye your hair like different colors all
the time no my hair has been blonde pink
red purple all sorts of colors and it's
not based on a man or any other person
it's just based on the fact that I like
my hair to be different colors yes she's
doing it for herself what do you do for
yourself regardless of how women will
look yeah I don't have like hair to dye
pink you know I wish I could you know
you're very lucky
okay if I had a pink
if I if I had a pink hair or pink beard
rather is that cool like pink beer yeah
was that like okay dye my peepsie I
don't have I mean if you have any I
don't pubes they're not pubes oh my God
what a freak yeah
after a certain age yeah I can confirm
you can yeah so we're on that note we're
done with our date okay oh okay well the
lady has said that she's done she had
enough all right this was fun
Keiko has said it's over
I told you be quiet John thank you Keiko
for being here you have the name of a
killer whale I told you be quiet John
you did not listen you could have gotten
names it was my fault I think it was
everybody John is killing it with the
words per minute
[Music]
you got the most out of the stage time
we got cat Raven rain we got rain rain
from the LGBT qia plus bucket we're
gonna get to know about rain
and maybe find her a date
rain is coming up thank you so much for
coming rain
you have tattoos we will not ask about
that because that can get messy it's all
right it's all right I don't mind so
rain what's the meaning behind that name
my brain like in rain right like water
yeah
um one result said pure the other said
Queen don't really like that pure Queen
don't like it you're fitting in
perfectly in Austin no I'm neither of
those things
what do you love about Austin
uh so I'd say the music scene is
probably the big one
um okay insulted you didn't say comedy
scene but go on
that's something I got into the last few
months but there's something for
everybody out here what was happening
before you got into comedy you were just
crying all the time yeah the pandemic
hit a year after I moved here and that
was like the first year I lived on my
own so it really [__] me up
um but you know we're vibing now like
it's kind of over right then I guess are
you a comedian no
no sometimes but never on purpose so
what got you interested in comedy
I was seeing a guy two months ago who
liked comedy uh actually the first show
I went to uh you were there and oh nice
he met you
um things are over now so I'm here by
myself oh wow he's probably a big fan
huh yes
and now you're uh is this revenge is
this Revenge um no
I was queer before I met him
um I kind of just
so he was so bad that he turned you bye
[Laughter]
um no I wouldn't give him that much
credit no
wow that real Keiko energies right now
[Music]
yeah I love it yeah yeah we're Asian I
feel great we have a lot of feminine
energy
rain what are you looking for in a date
tonight
feminine energy
hey I don't judge no judgment well this
is the part of the show where we try to
convert someone into being queer
uh
so far I see a lot of men any women want
to go on a date with rain yeah come on
up here we need a woman
preferably
not racist it can be a man I'm pansexual
okay
come on up here gopa
here he comes
he qualifies he has a pulse and he's
above 18. he have nice hair
thank you you too Ty 90 seconds with
Paul Cypher starting now how's it going
good you how old are you I am 25. all
right
if Twitter finds out about this it's
okay
um
nice curls thank you thank you is that
do you have to do anything to make that
happen every morning
really yeah yeah yeah I don't have to do
anything for my Luscious Hair see I
shaved my head once upon a time and and
that was nice wake up and just go have
you ever dyed it pink I tried uh it
didn't work
hahaha
[Music]
uh so are you are you from Austin I'm
from Boston Massachusetts [__] no really
yes okay I'm from there
okay those are two different places uh
although you know you know shittiness
we're both trash that's okay yes we're
both have are you uh
are you allowed to ask us on a date are
you a POC
ah I'm Brown yes okay
hahaha
I'm calling I'm colorblind
you can't tell by the hair no I cannot
I'm sorry
I'm not as you couldn't tell well I'm a
person of Canada I'm a French Canadian
American that's how I identify
that was not right that was not right
I don't have any connection with my
culture my parents moved here when I was
very little um
give it up for the liberal Paul Cypress
and Rain POC going on a date with the
d-i-c-k
[Laughter]
how's it going Hans great I'm very sorry
that I wasn't here to host the show
yes yeah but he wasn't here so I had to
fill in yeah I was supposed to be on the
stage on a date what I'm getting is that
you're unreliable and I uh that's a red
flag shows up late to a fight like the
French do but your hands are great
though are you better at that time
better to come too late than to come too
early am I right
I come extremely quick I've never made a
woman satisfied in my life so
um yeah no Hans switched it on me and I
have my phone on do not disturb I've
seen it was because Amy is filming a
special afterwards yes
the Jews really do control show business
huh so shout out to Amy Jewish comedian
Amy Schenker yes come check out our show
after this tonight but anyways enough
about you and your career and the
horrible this is a big opportunity for
man or bluest
so what is uh what why did you ask her
if she was POC were you like did your
Boston kick in yeah I don't know if I
should beat her up or if I
was like I don't know where the [__] is
she from dude I don't know I gotta ask a
kid uh yeah no I don't know so if I'm
I'm black I can't be from America no I
just met him that's how I was doing an
impression of all of my family members
not me
[Music]
we got Keiko back
I'm on a day with two women right now
dude I'm killing it Kika the feminist
Whisperer
she's here to be outraged for all of us
well based on your voice and attitude I
would never ask you that question it's
very clear
that there's a Caucasian lady in the
audience right now but um
stepping into defense
um
I don't uh yeah I would ask is that bad
you can't ask you can't ask because
that's kind of weird Hans are you a POC
yes
see
you know I don't know I'm trying to
learn about the world you know I'm
trying my best I mean if you had to
teach this white man something about the
world what would it be
so many things
you can change you can fix our society
forever right now no pressure that that
is a lot of pressure I would teach you
how you had correctly tie your shoes
what did I do wrong uh well most people
are uninformed and they uh they they do
the knot uh basically mirrored I watched
a two minute and 30 second Ted Talk one
time like five years ago and then had to
completely reteach myself how to tie my
shoe and
look at that
completely horizontal wow well we still
look terrible I think you're just a
hater no it's not like you know like you
can step on your shoe night says I know
I know Ty makes shoes so I know what I'm
talking about shoes
uh
Paul what do you think about going on a
date with rain do you think that maybe
you have too much white guilt to do it
or
I certainly uh have a lot of guilds I I
actually saw my name in the bucket
because I drove down here I want to be
on stage I actually am in a relationship
right now oh oh wow but I guess you're a
POS
laughs
uh but you know she she once she told me
that she would do a threesome with
another woman even though I think she
was probably uh
probably trying to trick me you know
they women will do that
for her not for you no she said that she
wanted to watch me like a reverse
cuckolding situation
damn why people be crazy yeah
actually she's Dominican so Dominican
people be crazy they do be crazy yeah
Bluetooth on the [__] Subway we all
know what the deal is but we could all
agree East Coast people now not even
once well thank you guys so much for
being on the show we do have to leave
but uh we really appreciate you guys
thank you rain for being here I
appreciate it all ciphers give it up for
them yeah they went on a date
Taiwan has been the guest tonight hi any
uh check him out on Instagram and
YouTube yeah coming out yeah check me
out on YouTube I have several comedy
specials he's got several uh we got Amy
Shanker here tonight after the show
please stick around you could be a part
of History she's recording her special
come watch she's very funny she killed
it yesterday yep uh that's been the show
give it up for Aaron hug he likes his
butthole
thank you